buonasera a tutti grazie ad essere qua
grazie ad alessandro lo ied e sono
giulio xhaet cognome un po strano perché
se lo chiede sono belga di origine e in
questi dieci minuti mi sono del giorno
club ora che ci portassimo a casa due o
tre concetti che faccio formazione
sparato prima di formazione
il robot è contento perché noi cerchiamo
proprio di formazione per le aziende per
i ragazzi non soprattutto per l'ambito
della comunicazione del marketing
digitale
ora che ci portassimo a casa qualche
concetto che io mi sta particolarmente a
cuore innanzitutto quello del codice
umanistico vediamo cosa si intende che
cos'è e poi insomma una sorta di vorrei
che fosse un po di più di una lista
della spesa con le varie professioni
digitali muove che si collegano a questo
codice umanistico perché ciascuna di
esse è qualcosa forse più di una
professione in quanto si collega ad un
talento specifico fatti proprio il
concetto con importazioni a casa è
talenti per le professioni digitali
infatti se c'era un tempo in cui
internet era un luogo per soli
smanettoni qualcuno direbbe per i matici
oggi le cose sono cambiate
non sto qua a ripeterlo perché lo
sappiamo tutti ma da un luogo in cui
luogo agito un luogo comunicato un luogo
vissuto d'achille delle competenze una
passione molto tecnologica informatica
oggi le cose sono molto cambiate
attenzione non sto parlando male degli
informatici assolutamente sciocco a loro
perché altrimenti non fosse per loro e
non sarei qua a parlare di nulla in
quanto socio parte invece di
qualcos'altro di un codice che potremmo
definire umanistico ovvero tutta quella
serie di persone che sono appassionate o
che hanno sviluppato delle competenze
livello informazione appunto a livello
scolastico poi competenza in ambito
professionale che sono più legate alla
creatività al marketing alla
comunicazione mandiamo anche alla
sociologia come vedremo la psicologia e
la linguistica la filosofia che oggi
possono trovare della declinazione
concreta a livello professionale nel
digitale e quindi mi piace proprio
definire tutte queste nuove
professionalità che attenzione non sono
in conflitto ma assolutamente in
integrazione tra codice informatico i
nostri cari di smanettoni in cui mi
piacerà confrontare in tutti i giorni e
il codice umanistico praticamente chi
lavora dentro la rete un po chi naviga
sopra comunicando sopra la rete il
possiamo definire una una serina tipo di
tipologie di professionisti e questo
tipo lo questa segmentazione arriva
proprio strana estraendo il talento
specifico di ognuno lo abbiamo suddiviso
in questo modo perché ci sono diverse
professioni il codice umanistico che
riguardano diversi ambiti diverse
competenze ora non abbiamo il tempo di
esplodere tutte ma diamo un'occhiata
allora avete pazienza sono anche delle
terminologie anglofone un po
futuristiche un po provocatorie cos'è
stata la sfida web editor il creatore
dei contenuti
c'è qualche giornalista in sala di suo
zio cosa sta dicendo stop site
sto parlando di chi crea i contenuti
quindi il concetto è bene io so a
livello praticamente testuale
multimediale visivo con delle immagini
dei video creare del contenuto che
s'apre virare in rete quale deve essere
il mio talento
la cosa più banale del mondo che mi dire
te va bene grazie tante ci sei arrivato
avere una voce caratteristica ma questo
è ancora più vero oggi
perché perché se fino a qualche anno fa
all'epoca pre internet internet per
darci delle etichette 1.0 i creatori di
contenuti erano tendenzialmente pochi o
non tantissimi pensiamo a giornalisti
autori a fotografi a cineasti oggi
quante persone invece possono
improvvisarsi o provare a fare per torre
di contenuti attraverso il blog un sito
attraverso la piattaforma come instagram
o come youtube o come nuove conoscere ad
esempio va in bici permettono diventare
potenzialmente di creature di contenuti
ecco che quindi c'è tantissima gente che
si propone di fare questo
chi è che alla fine però viene fuori chi
davvero dimostra d'avere una voce
propria caratteristica e questo lo
lascio qui un attimo un attimo hanno
sospeso questo discorso perché chi crea
il contenuto è il la professione che più
sento vicina volevo chiudere proprio con
un accenno ancora finale quindi il
concetto vorrei che lascia siamo qua una
voce caratteristica e come ci ricorda
comincerò all'anie che un innovatore
se un intenso e molto famoso attenzione
prima di condividere pensiate
pensate ad essere pensate ai vostri
contenuti che cosa sono gli for two year
justy la seconda professione sempre
legata al contenuto in una professione
premente la più nuova di cui si sente
parlare poco adesso in italia ma che
negli stati uniti giani così gli style
matrice anglosassone si sta già parlando
molto vero non solo chi crea contenuti
ex novo ma chi cura contenuti di altri
perché molto spesso in rete c'è già la
maggior parte di tutto quello che ci può
interessare
se devo fare un contenuto nuovo su una
news
il fatto che sta accadendo un concetto
che voglio sviluppare un evento molto
probabilmente la maggiore ci sono già
delle persone che hanno già creato dei
contenuti testuali lange lanciato dei
tweet in rete hanno infatto delle
immagini dei video un lavoro è quello di
riuscire a filtrare e condividere le
migliori informazioni che trovano in
rete attenzione non solo un copia
incolla banale ma i bravi conta in
curator's sanno come dare una propria
impronta caratteristica a questo patch
work creativo
in rete quindi conta in curation il
fatto è proprio sapere il col talento
filtrare e condividere le migliori
informazioni da questo potremmo dire
overload mare magnum di continuo
informazioni in rete e dare riprenderà
il meglio caratteristico infatti clay
shirky che è un motore estremamente
autorevole vivi chiede molto spesso alle
aziende ma soffrite di averlo di
informazioni
avete fallito nel filtraggio avete
fallito nella content curation equa cito
anche un altro attore molto interessante
e che viene fuori con un libro nicholas
carr dal titolo emblematico internet ci
rende stupidi punti di domanda io
rispondo si potrebbe molto facilmente se
non sappiamo dominare questo eccesso di
informazioni quindi il concetto è saper
cura creare ma anche curare
altrimenti internet non è un luogo che
ci permette di dominare degli strumenti
ma di cui siamo dominati ma perché le
slide un po matti terza professione di
cui si parla molto perché community
manager vuol dire molto spesso social
media manager per molti merita non è
esattamente così
perché una community non è fatta
semplicemente da social media come
facebook twitter linkedin eccetera
e i social media non sono solo internet
community mora non entriamo nello
specifico il community manager è colui
che gestisce
ed è il punto gestore portavoce di una
comunità online ed è colui che come
direbbe il buon mark zuckerberg che
dicono mi ci capisce qualcosa visto che
gestisce con la più grande al mondo un
miliardo 200 milioni utenti e detenzione
e fate attenzione le unity non si creano
le community si intercettano perché si
sono già sono gli appassionati di
qualche cosa
io prendo atto non cito ad esempio in
mente la community di heineken senza non
el'ad di heineken community e la
community si chiama isle of beer che ha
intercettato gli appassionati e quelli
che vogliono far andare a farsi una
bevuta magari la sera esistevano già
prima non doveva arrivare il community
manager di anche per creata questa
community
il community manager quale talento deve
dimostrare di possedere attenzione
perché qua andiamo a toccare i tasti
perché chi pensa a quanto conta avere
tecnica quanto conta avere abilità
relazionali meno toccare il tasto della
tia e l'empatia è qualche cosa che va
molto oltre il codice informatico si
avvicino al codice umanistico infatti
vuol dire sapersi mettere nei panni
degli altri quindi non conta tanto saper
comunicare qualche cosa conta avere la
capacità di relazionarsi all'interno di
una comunità di persone saper leggere
tra le righe dell'empatia degli altri
non per nulla i migliori molti fra i
migliori community manager all'estero
soprattutto guardate caso arrivano da
studi prevalentemente psicologia e
filosofia quarto le digital pr e digital
piazze parla molto come evoluzione o
integrazione delle ufficio stampa
classico delle relazioni pubbliche delle
misere nation passando però dalle public
relation come acronimo di persone tipo
relation come lo diciamo a ingaggiare
coinvolgere i cosiddetti influencer
influenti della rete blogger e
personaggi autorevoli il concetto qua ce
lo spiega benissimo ieri bene ciò che è
un imprenditore davvero tosto noi quelli
forti che si è fatto da solo a quelli
come start upper e dice guardate per
qualcuno sono evidente per un altro
molto meno per molte aziende non lo è
assolutamente non conta quanti fan e
conti pollo ai contano le relazioni
corato non è vastità e profondità cosa
vuol dire questo per il digital pr
tensione un mondo in cui l'accesso ad
avere tanti contatti nuovi è facilissimo
vado su facebook trovo mille amici 2000
amici vado su linkedin sono mille
contatti addosso linkedin e cominciò a
follower la gente ma il punto è che
questo accesso facilitato ad arrivare al
contatto è inversamente proporzionale
alla capacità di instaurare un vero
legame con queste persone
certo provate a diventare amici di mille
persone su linkedin poi chiedete a loro
di lanciare un comunicato stampa se non
avete instaurato una relazione vera non
avete dedicato tempo a fare network in
maniera consistente sarà completamente
inutile quindi l'abilità del talento di
chi fa le pr è di passare dai frammenti
della rete alle persone in rete che è
una cosa completamente diversa
quinto chi fa pubblicità online invece
usa strumenti come facebook advertising
google adwords display advertising
quest'altra acronimi che stanno a
significare invece che andare a
investire in pubblicità offline
televisione stampa radio eccetera
io vado in rete e creò le mie campagne
pubblicitarie benissimo e sono gli
strumenti che gli permettono di farlo
sono strumenti innovativi molto
interessanti e qua il talento di che se
ne occupa e avere una visione e una
gestione capacità di visione gestione
multi canale integrata tra tutti questi
strumenti che poi devo saper gestire
direttamente con un budget
ok a differenza digital pr qua io devo
gestire una persona il cui pago il tempo
che ci mette a costruire reti di
relazioni qua pago direttamente degli
strumenti
ok e come ricordava il buongiorno haker
che è una start up per di qualche del
1860 addirittura non si parlava ancora
così di crisi la metà dei soldi che
spende in pubblicità è sprecata diceva e
poi si che non se manco balestra netta
ora invece siamo una situazione diversa
perché la pubblicità si legga questo al
fatto che ne possiamo tracciare
attraverso lavoro della web analytics
tutto quello che viene speso
direttamente in rete
ok sono arrivato alla fine del tempo
vedo già alessandro che mi sta passando
da così a così tra un po passerà ancora
un minuto finito la web analytics
praticamente tratta delle persone che
devono capire come interpretare i dati
di accesso alle proprie al proprio sito
ai propri progetti direttamente online
quindi dati di analisi quanti accessi
abbiamo fatto come le persone navigano e
se lo colleghiamo qua la pubblicità io
posso sapere io resto hicks quanto mi
ritorna per ogni y che io investo una
cosa che era assolutamente impensabile
con la pubblicità classica perché se io
do 10 mila euro per fare una pubblicità
su un giornale e non posso sapere dove
vanno a finire gli investimenti e non
posso modificare in corsa qua invece
posso siamo gli ultimi due il reputation
management sempre dati statistici ma a
differenza della web analytics qua
parliamo di conversazioni rilevanti
ovvero io posso andare a studiare capire
chi sono le persone che stanno parlando
di me la mia azienda o di qualcosa che
mi può interessare direttamente in rete
vedo chi ne parla quanto ne parla come
ne parla il talento qua prima aveva
parlato di formazione in ambito
psicologia filosofia bene qua che ha
fatto scienze della comunicazione come
il sottoscritto che nell'epoca lì si
diceva se hai fatto scienza delle
merendine io non capivo bene cosa fosse
la scienza della comunicazione
ho studiato linguistica linguistica una
realtà che un attitudine e una serie di
competenze che vengono fuori molto molto
in maniera maniera molto utile per chi
vuole fare lì reputation management
perché deve lavorare proprio con la
lingua o come diverse lingue il talento
qualità per capire come interpretare
elementi linguistici semantici ed
estrarli dalla rete
last but not least diciamo il più
smanettone del gruppo qua borderline tra
come dice umanissimo informatico il
search engine optimizer ovvero colui che
è capace di ottimizzare delle strategie
che ci permettono di essere molto
visibili nei motori di ricerca se dico
motore di ricerca dico al 97 per cento
google e in questo caso il talento e
proprio l'abilità nel testing ovvero
sapere sperimentare sempre nuove
soluzioni il seo bravo è quello che non
si
che non si accontenta di una soluzione
molto semplice ma riesce a trovare il
modo per cui per certe parole chiave
io con la mia attività so essere nelle
prime pagine di google e questo è
importantissimo anche essere alla prima
soprattutto pagina di google perché come
si dice tra i seo il modo migliore per
nascondere un cadavere dove e metterlo
nella seconda pagina di google dove
praticamente nessuno quasi ci va ora so
che sono proprio un minuto per chiudere
con una cosa rapidissima mi dicevo
all'inizio kicker ei contenuti sono
molto affezionato e dicevo qual è il
talento di fichera i contenuti
allora una voce caratteristica mi
permetto di riprendere un riassumere
brevemente un testo che a me proprio
molto caro lo conoscete parametrici
fahrenheit 451 di ray bradbury due
statunitensi anni 60 c questa storia
questo libro dove in cui si narra un
mondo distopico vero utopico al
contrario un brutto posto dove vivere
nel futuro in cui la cultura viene rasa
a 0 proprio tabula rasa nel vero senso
della parola venne proprio bruciata
stampo un po nazista infatti farà
neanche 251 e alla gradazione nei gradi
celsius in cui d'agra la cellulosa
cominciare praticamente in questo futuro
e esistono degli agenti del del futuro
del proprio dei punti e richiamando
nella casa delle persone e bruciano i
libri delle persone che li nascondono
dentro ancora che non vogliono bruciare
i libri perché si bruciano i libri
perché si pensa che sapere troppo forti
a pensare troppo porti essere tristi
porti a essere meno produttivi il
protagonista che un agente del futuro
questo montague banca stranissima di
questa grandissima in questa giornata
questa signora molto anziana che
nascondono b2 tiche immenso di libri
tirano fuori tutto ma pure mese i libri
un libricino top cade per terra non
raccoglie incuriosito negi david
copperfield di questo charles dickens
melo non lo metto in tasca incuriosito
anche se non si può torna a casa è più
un bambino perché ovviamente non leggi
solo alle informazioni pubblicitarie dei
cartelloni comincia a leggere riga per
riga a finisce dice che roba pazzesca
quindi tu volta che va in missione
quando riesce va a rubare il libro di
quelli che dovrebbe essere declinati
alla fiera al alla fiamma arriva alla
fine nella società ma alla fine la
storia arriva la moglie non sa niente
scopre nascondiglio in caso di questi
libri questa piccola biblioteca è matta
di terrore diceva che cosa ci trovi in
questi stupidi libri perché il
raccontato questo mi sono reso conto in
questi anni che questo è verissimo anche
se diciamo cosa ci trovi questo stupido
blog procedurali questo stupido sito
reciterà vico la fan page di quell
azienda di quel tipo di quella cosa è
sempre di più proprio perché siamo
sempre di più immersi in tanti blog in
tanti creatori di contenuti
a me interessa quel qualcosa il
contenuto che trovo in rete se dietro
quel contenuto ci trovo questa roba qua
una persona e non è facile vi assicuro
quando una persona riesce a venir fuori
dei propri contenuti
allora vuol dire che è un ottimo
creatore di contenuti un ottimo
protagonista del codice umanistico bene
io vi ringrazio
subito bene nel tempo spero